hello everyone welcome to the Tiger
Billy podcast we are talking very quiet
right now if you're watching on video as
you can see right now it is very dark in
the room there are some light up
balloons there are regular balloons
there is Bryce in the corner there is
George by the camera are you giving the
shot George wave your hand somewhere
without your head there's his hand can't
see SH it's too dark we're gonna
probably cut this part but you know no
I'm creating the scenes about dairy for
audio listeners still texting people you
know I'm trying to we're we're
whispering it's Bobby's birthday today
and kalila took Bobby out for a dinner
at a fancy Italian restaurant and took
him for a dessert to stall time for us
to set up the room and we're gonna
surprise Bobby and got directly in the
podcast so we're gonna leave the cameras
running we're gonna leave the audio all
the mics hot so that you guys can join
us it's experience of surprising our
leader our cat has no chance we cut out
any dead time you're gonna hear all of
what's happening it's gonna be live and
exciting you know every minute you're
gonna get to hear it
you know well we like wonder if they're
no they're not at the door right now we
didn't hear a thing well so what you did
get a text alright yes text tell it
audience with the text said the text
said we're in the basement so they're in
the basement they're probably in an
elevator right now I assume they've had
enough time to get out of the elevator
but light the candles I know no no no
you were [ __ ] dumb no whistle what if
he walks directly in here what if he
walks directly then it's better than the
[ __ ] water going off because these
set off a smoke alarm do you see how
many [ __ ] candles there are as I say
those cameras show me where the alarm is
looking at clicked alarm look at those
candles so it's it's not here
Bobby get out because he didn't want to
show the batter hey poppy just entered
in right now they're trying to light the
candles they told me
I've got one gift I've got one candle in
the camera okay Poppy's here oh damn it
I don't know why I have to be the one
that's doing it I can hear kalila but
but this is what this is what we do for
our captain for our leader or young we
we put a bunch of Red Bulls put up
[Applause]
[Music]
guys we are at the tiger belly podcast
you were with us for 20 minutes while we
set this up Bobby is in the room the
king himself our leader he's very happy
this is the happiest I've ever seen he's
not annoyed by any of this
koalas here as well the podcast is Bobby
how do you feel well we have for you as
some Red Bulls some dream waters glue
this is how I wanted to start you don't
want a cake well I don't know what kind
of cake is it well first of all can I
say this that was genuinely surprised
yeah this question am i happy are you if
I'm happy Bobby are you happy no I knew
it are there actually 47 candles on
there it's 47 it's too many what can I
say this candle the light the rest
shut up for something it's my [ __ ]
birthday birthday Joe hogging the mic do
with your [ __ ] voice what happened
she already shot you started you started
the podcast already yeah about eight
minutes ago and what did you guys talk
about it was just setting up and then
just George talking the whole time
[Laughter]
thinking about candles like a no they
they could turn off the fire alarms we
like to read because he said the fire
would go off I said there's no [ __ ]
fire alarm oh yeah he ripped them all
off here's the mystery I came in the
house yeah I go why the dogs trapped in
the bedroom what did I say and you're
like well you said something about oh
well Ramy probably figured out how to
get in there how good of an actor am i
wait what were you expect we're not
supposed to be trapped no when we come
in the house they're not in the bedroom
we lock them out we keep out in the
living room so that was written astray
number one interesting and then number
two is like um did somebody walk the
dogs no I don't know maybe Kyle
because when I came in on my shy walk
the dog and she's like you don't have to
which is really weird like what she's
like babe walk the dog
[Music]